and you were sad and skinny so i spent a
lot of time i did i did the work yeah
for two years right and then i
transferred to northwestern university
to the theater program there
and that's then it was completely
different than
then that was the beginning of my new
life did it turn around did your sadness
turn around do you remember the day was
there no the sadness did not turn around
no i didn't know a matter of fact in
some ways it was worse because i was
being asked to confront it directly
because we were doing sort of method
work
and and were you able to uh not very
well i i not very well i remember my my
teacher ann woodworth the wonderful
teacher who i learned so much from
didn't even realize how much i learned
from until i'd gone to try to work
professionally for years yeah and then
went oh this is what she was teaching me
um
she
saw through a lot of my [ __ ] yeah
and my
charm
and my i was vassel i could learn lines
very quickly i could get a sense of how
the scene might work but there wasn't a
lot of emotional truth to the work that
i did and she kept on saying but how do
you feel and i remember blowing up at
her once
anger oh blowing up with her because she
wasn't buying yeah my
uh well
uh well-constructed facsimile of human
emotion for her
and she and remember she's saying then
how do you feel
how do you actually feel i'm like i feel
fine really how do you feel and i
remember her sitting on the edge of the
stage and me without out of nowhere not
knowing how it happened me
uh
like
looming over her
like a wave about to break on her
because i'm standing on stage she's
sitting on the edge and she's not
looking at me she's sort of looking off
to the side me going i don't
like
yelling
not even at you
and you want me
to yell
and she just said
how do you feel
like that and it completely undid me did
you cry yeah absolutely just like
classic
you know acting class as therapy which
it should not be
right you know really gets mistaken for
therapy a lot and i that's one of the
reasons why i love barry that tv show is
so brilliant so good so it's perfect and
everything i watched it like it's
perfect in every way and i recognize
that acting class
so perfectly but like that's that moment
though where you know without
understanding it the relationship
between sadness and anger is is very
close because anger is not really your
emotion right anger is your last armor
right before you show your actual like i
felt when you just did that exercise and
explanation i felt it like i felt that
the that because i'm a guy who lives in
a certain or did in a certain amount of
anger out of fear of being engulfed by
the sadness sure
like that like or to be judged for your
feelings well yeah i i don't know for me
it was vulnerability too to be seen as
these these feelings were so
debilitating but it's all you want to do
is be seen though
really yes
you want to be seen but instead you
create some very close version of
yourself for people to see yeah innately
it's not like you're seeing it going on
no no no no no no right it's just it's
yeah it snaps together without legos
that like i've been a version of you
snaps together like legos without even
thinking about it and i'm at this place
right now in my life where i'm like i
can't i don't want to manage that [ __ ]
anymore what am i so afraid of you know
like that like if i if i open that up it
will never the crying will never stop
[Music]
yes
if you if you pay any attention
if you pay any attention to the world
the crying will never stop that's right
it's true
you know that it just kind of locks in
with the the sadness that's already
there yeah if you already have that yeah
yeah yeah so that's a daily thing man
yeah right
all right so so so i have that's a bit
of a breakthrough when i realized oh i'm
i kind of realized that moment oh i am
which is obvious of course but you don't
i'm not looking at myself again i'm
shaving looking at a cork board i'm not
really looking at the mirror right and
that was one of those moments oh this
one oh i guess i am damaged and and my
teacher actually said i won't teach you
anymore unless you go to therapy oh wow
did you yeah i did yeah and help
yeah a little bit i mean i took it
mildly seriously yeah it's like i
realized wait all i did was like open me
to the idea that i got a lot of work to
do yeah and then then i didn't do that
work no you can hold on to that idea
like i just recently re-engaged that
idea like within the last few weeks i've
got a lot of work to do i've got work to
do i'm going to go do it yep and then i
didn't do it no i didn't do it but at
least you know a she kept me in her
class
and and also i i became at least at
least aware enough to know that i've got
a lot of unresolved stuff going on and i
wonder what that is
still not not as much no no not
that time yeah did the work do itself no
you 100 did not do itself i had a
nervous breakdown when i was 29. like
literally like
10 years after i don't do the work 10
years later i had a nervous i like
completely like i wouldn't wish this
panic attack on anyone i wouldn't wish i
wouldn't wish on anyone but my worst
enemies i wouldn't want to make feel the
way i felt for months at 29 29 yeah yeah
so a month married one month married how
about that how's that a wedding present
for your wife is that the guy that she
thought she married she comes home she's
like what did you do all day i'm like
walking tight circles around the couch
yeah you know like how was your day and
like you're looking at it because i was
just
like if i physically kept moving if i
physically kept moving like it wouldn't
get me oh you know from the inside well
back here back in the peripheral vision
oh you can't see it it's always there
yeah the worst possible thing that'll
ever happen right right which must never
be named yeah or ever be known right you
just to stay steady just busy just keep
moving just keep moving keep going that
was at 29 yeah